any candidates who wish to join me on
the platform please now join me for the
Howland constituency okay I the
undersigned being the acting returning
officer at the election held on Thursday
the 7th of May 2015 to hereby give
notice number of votes for each
candidate is cast as follows Nick Clegg
twenty two thousand two hundred and
fifteen
Stephen clay English Democrats 167
oliver coppered labor
19800 six ago
Peter Peter Peter garvik's Green Party
1772 Joe Jenkins you Kip 3575
Carlton Reeve independent 249 Jim stop
the fiasco wild 97 Ian Walker
conservative 7500 21 rejected votes and
I hereby declare that Nick Clegg has
been duly elected thank you
can I um can I thank could I thank you
can I thank you John mother soul as
returning officer for all your work and
that of your team and that of all the
staff in the polling stations and here
at the counters well and of course to
the police and all the emergency
services in ensuring that the election
has gone so smoothly in sheffield hallam
i'd obviously also like to thank all the
candidates all my opponents perhaps most
especially oliver copepod for a very
dynamic and vigorous contest which was
held in sheffield hallam
though though I suspect I suspect the
residents of sheffield hallam will be
quite relieved that the torrent of
campaign literature is now no longer
making its way through their letter
boxes I'd like to thank Andy Sanger my
agent and my wonderful campaign team I
really couldn't wish for a better team
of outstanding campaigners and activists
you believe in what you do and you do it
brilliantly thank you very very much
indeed and of course I'd like to convey
my thanks to Miriam who is here and our
three little boys who are not it is not
always easy to have a husband and a
father in a family where I've been
involved for ten years now in the
sometimes brutal frontline of British
politics but above all my thanks goes to
the residents of Sheffield Hallam who
have once again shown their confidence
in me and I'm very very grateful and
humbled by their confidence in me I know
of course that many voters did not
support me this time and had done so
previously and my message to them is
very simple is the greatest honour of my
political life to have served this
wonderful part of this wonderful city
and I will always work diligently in
Westminster on all of their behalf on
behalf of all communities and all
families across Sheffield Hallam turning
to the national picture it is now
painfully clear that this has been a
cruel and punishing night for the
Liberal Democrats
the election has profound implications
for the country it also obviously has
profound implications for the Liberal
Democrats and I will be seeking to make
further remarks about the implications
of this election both for the country
and for the party that I lead and for my
position in the Liberal Democrats when I
make remarks to my colleagues in the
Liberal Democrats later this morning
when I return to Westminster thank you
very much